zahnschmerzen
okay die erste moment es gibt euch weg
und ok also außer den veranschlagten wie
ist die lage schon wieder diese frage ja
die frage sie sagen ist ganz okay was
entwickelt was hat sich entwickelt
es läuft aber in allen richtungen in
jeder richtung geschäft läuft albums
steht wieder an der tür schon eine
eigene sendung alpa gun tv und bin gut
reingekommen auf youtube auf youtube
genau auf meinen eigenen channel alpa
gun channel tv tv channels die serie
kommt eine rolle gespielt hat man eine
gute rolle eine hauptrolle dieses mal
keine nebenrolle und sind so einige
sachen jetzt wieder an den ich mit
beteiligen
was läuft du hast mitgeschrieben
blutsbruder mit sido das waren eben
alles war die nehmen das habe ich nicht
so nebenbei ja aber wie kommt man als
rapper eine hauptrolle schauspiel nicht
lernen müssen es schaffen ich hab's
unchained im blut ok ich glaube die
rolle die nebenrolle habe ich an
scheinen so gut gespielt dass ich dann
halt auch gleich danach angefragt wurde
für die serie und auf jeden fall als
statische bock drauf das hat das
wichtigste und ich hatte doch zeit und
deswegen habe ich es mitgemacht und habt
ihr auch gut so es ist natürlich eine
herausforderung sich umzustellen und
eine person aber die rolle fehlen mir
jetzt auch nicht allzu schwer aber ich
könnte noch andere größere rollen
schwächte der weitermachen oder wo
willst du weitermachen also musik ist
mein hauptberuf sag ich mal so mein
hauptjob
aber ich bin künstler ich habe mir sind
entdeckt dass ich halten auch andere
sache kann aus der texte schreiben und
es sofort zu tragen so musikalischen
richtungen
ich glaube vor der kamera da habe ich
schon eine große stärke wenn musik ist
also da muss ja in die kamera form aber
ich kann es anscheinend auch halten in
die kamera zu gucken und zu performen
die kamera darf er dann gar nicht für
dich da sein
genau das darf man nicht beachten man
muss halt in seiner rolle sind in der
person und man macht sich natürlich auch
kopf und gedanken wie man die person so
darstellen kann
mit man improvisiert halt doch selber
und samir in der rolle hat verbrechen
fiel es mir jetzt auch nicht so schwer
den kleinkriminellen zu spielen wieso
hast du da erfahrung ein bisschen schon
aber mittlerweile bin ich natürlich
erwachsen und er geworden
natürlich haben wir mit so etwas nicht
zu tun da war mal jung und irgendwo dumm
und hat gelernt
außerdem fehlen hat fehler gemacht und
wir shop meine erfahrung hat positiv mit
weiter genommen mein leben so wann war
der wein wann dabei jeder punkt wo du
gesagt hast das wird mir zu heiß also wo
du umgeschwenkt hat und sagt mir ich
will nichts mehr anstellen ist mit so
mehr wo ich gemerkt habe es kann halt
alles auch anders sein
es läuft zwar gut wenn du irgendwo wenn
wir zum beispiel auf der straße ein
bisschen geld machst und aber irgendwann
kann es auch schnell und dann muss man
halt auch die die böse seite auch mit
berechnen so also die gute seite schwarz
gesetzen der seite die noch die dich als
werkzeug nehmen ich habe damit gerechnet
was ist was passiert wenn ich reinkomme
anpasst oder ein verhängnis
es war schon heiß und deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht okay das war beim warum ist
ihr schicksal
ich habe ja sie dumm zu kennengelernt
als ich noch tätig war auf der straße
und dann habe ich mir gedacht okay hier
gibt es vielleicht einen anderen weg nur
mit musik talent in mir entdeckt dass
ich texte schreiben kann und ich habe
genug zu erzählen und es war für mich
wichtig ich habe auch vielleicht
irgendwo glück gehabt mein engel haben
mich beschützt vielleicht aber da dachte
ich mache natürlich irgendwann kommt
alles zurück ich hab halt flash nicht
alles legal geschafft so in der zeit und
nicht dass wir irgendetwas irgendwann
alles gut aus der nase raus kommt und so
glaub und mein glaube gibst du was auch
und alles kommt so dass irgendwann genau
wenn ich in diesem leben dann im
nächsten leben und da habe ich natürlich
hat auch angst gehabt und habe versucht
habe den richtigen weg versucht zu
nehmen und es ist der schwarzer es ist
schwerer er härter man erkennt daran
dass man keine angst haben muss vor der
polizei wenn man im auto sitzt okay wenn
die polizei sich anhält dann kannst du
mit mit einem gewissen sagen ja ich
fahre zum auftritt und dann sind sie
sogar cool zu dir echt was machst du
denn ich mache musik man habe ich
zufälligerweise ein album gesamtmarkt du
machst du echt musik und nebenbei ein
bisschen schauspielern und so hey bist
ja gut wann kommt man sagen wo kann ich
das von ihr sehen weißt du aber
andersrum hat macht ihr bekommt ihr habt
ihr habt ihr irgendwelche sachen im auto
oder irgendwelche waffen den ich mit
vielen dürft oder sowas weste also man
hat einen ruhigen gewissens und man weiß
dass man alles richtig macht zu hause
sagt auch mehr ruhe bei den eltern
damals jetzt bist du natürlich in einer
beziehung mit einer frau
und da hast halt ein gutes gewissen dass
du arbeitest wenn dass ich irgendwann
mal auszeit dann ist man irgendwo mehr
stolz auf sich weil man hat es halt auf
den geraden weg geschafft und man hat
halt auch ein bisschen gelitten
es gab schlechte zeiten und wenn man
sein durchzieht und am ende dafür
belohnt wird dann schmeckt das geld um
so besser oder das was du isst es dieses
gefühl sein und nicht jeder zeit kann
die tür ein krachen und sek kommt rein
und keine ahnung jemand hat mich
verraten
reste slaves ruhiger mann schläft im
umfeld von sido
da hast du gesagt bist du zum rappen
gekommen wie ohne wie viele leute sind
in so einem umfeld und wieviel fange an
zu rappen ich sag mal fängt der fahrer
auch an zu retten und ich habe keine
ahnung wer oder wie kommt das dass sich
das dann herauskristallisiert sagt sie
du jedem empfangen sag mal was du kannst
oder wie kommt das nicht
ich habe als sich die damals im studio
besucht habe die studie bei mir um die
ecke schob er um die ecke gewohnt und
ich habe es halt nicht so weit zu denen
deswegen haben die mich wahrscheinlich
öfter angerufen weil die mich gebracht
haben wir haben sie gemerkt öffentlich
gemacht haben indem sie was zu rauchen
gebracht haben ok beste und dann steht
man da und das sogar enten geholt
automaten angebracht und
eine zigarette geraucht sich unterhalten
besser kennengelernt
coole mucke cool gemacht wird so auch
mal versuchen
oder ich hab halt auch auf dem hof
bisschen nebenbei mit meinen jungs ein
bisschen auch versucht ein bisschen zu
retten aber ich habe zeit nie so ernst
und dann habe ich bei den gesehen wie
professionell gearbeitet um es
professionell gearbeitet der sekte
also ich hätte nie gedacht dass sie
jetzt sofort schreiben und aufnehmen
ist ja auch eine menge 16 takte und da
wollte ich auch so was machen ich wollte
auch von mir erzählen ich habe auch viel
zu erzählen ich wollte auch so
professionell arbeiten wie turn gleich
hinsetzen überlege über was schwäbisch
paar beispiele und dann das
zusammenfasst und das ist für mich eine
kunst und irgendwo macht doch spaß wenn
man dann am ende hört was man gelebt hat
und dann habe ich das halt auch versucht
neben den und irgendwann meinte sido hat
mich gefragt ob ich ob ich nicht mit ihm
auf tour gehen kann auf seiner tour
damals maskat uhr und erst mal wollte
ich ihr seid nicht weil ich war mir
unsicher auf der bühne zu stehen und
mikrofon und das war etwas ganz neues
für mich und ich hab dann natürlich ein
geschäft zu verdienen
jeden tag geld eingebracht hatte hatten
sie und ich gerät wer hat sich aus dem
sumpf quasi auf dachte ich okay las
dachte ich dass er mich aus dem sumpf
ross geholt
aber dann war ich die ganze zeit mit dem
unterwegs shop bei seine texte studiert
aber gelernt da habe ich auch gelernt
wie man räumt beste wo die ränge sind
die struktur habe stände entdeckt und
dann habe ich mit meinen worten mit
meinen geschichten versucht halt texte
zu schreiben wenn sie zu hause und zu
hause bei meinen eltern war dann halt
auch waren sie als auch beruhigt weil
die im zimmer immer beats gehört haben
damit acht der junge ist ganz brav zu
hause und schreit daraus erwacht auch
beim presse und davor hat sie immer
geguckt was macht er da dann verpackt da
irgendwas oder was ist da wieder los
rechnen sie waren zu hause ab bricht für
mich war es dann halt auch der weg ok
scheiß auf die straße ich versuche etwas
neues so lange ich noch jung bin ich
habe geld gespart damals beste und
absolute grenze und natürlich habe ich
auch verlust gehabt wenn weil ich war
auf tour und konnte mich mal auf der
straße meine sachen machen ich konnte
keine umsätze machen beste habe ich
drauf geschissen
ich dachte vielleicht kommt mit musik
etwas gutes und
die jahre sind vergangen und am ende
habe ich gemerkt dass ich halt nicht das
hat nicht so war wie es mir vorgestellt
habe ich habe halt nicht genug verdient
heute habe ich mich auch gefragt bevor
ich ehrensache gemacht habe ob sport von
musik leben kann weil bei mir läuft es
nicht keiner kümmert sich richtig um
mich jeder selber zu tun mit seiner
karriere
es gibt niemanden der mich manager der
für mich anruft und macht und ich bin
nicht die person gewesen für so was
spielen junge von der straße
wenn ich irgendwelche leute anrufen und
fragen will er kennt mich da rein
bringen und hier bringen dann nach zwei
sätzen hören was das für ein deutsch
unternehmen die mich gar nicht mal ernst
weil ich kann mich halt nicht so gut
artikulieren wie ein manager der in der
schule weil er studiert hat oder keine
ahnung oder der ist der ahnung hat
ahnung von sowas hat und dann habe ich
mich gefragt ob ich dann noch diese
schiene gehen kann allein mit talent
funktioniert es nicht und jetzt habe ich
mir halt ein team aufgebaut lang freunde
und familie nächste chance die mir dann
nämlich dann wache schüttet haben oder
gerettet haben heißt kommt man zu dir du
musst noch jetzt einen drauf legen jetzt
musste erst recht kämpfen du hast etwas
aufgebaut
du bist ein produkt es gibt leute die
dich feiern die was von gehören wollen
und sie wollen genau das hören was du
gerade durch machst du hast was einen
falschen träumen so dass man seine
träume sind wasser gefallen ja aber
genau das muss für zehnten dann wenn ich
zu mir gekommen und tappten den stift
und einem blatt papier genau überlegt
jetzt erzähle ich den leuten wie es
wirklich ist und ich bin ein mensch der
gerne die wahrheit sagt also ich bin
wirklich kein lügner
das ist nicht meine masche und ich will
den leuten etwas vormachen ich wollte
den leuten einfach nur erzählen was ich
durchgemacht habe wie ich zu dem punkt
jetzt gekommen bin und dass ich auch
wirklich stolz drauf bin dass ich es mit
ehrensache auf platz zwölf geschafft
habe dass ich wenigstens eine nebenrolle
noch bewiesen habe dass noch eine rolle
kriege und das ist jetzt nächstes album
wieder auf die beiden kräder dass eine
sendung alpa gun tv und
dann natürlich kriegst du damit wie die
hater wieder platzen und dann merkst du
dass ich alles richtig gemacht habe sie
würden jetzt beschäftigt über mich reden
die würden mich gar nicht ernst nehmen
wenn ich jetzt irgendwo eine ecke sitzen
wird und auf alles geschossen hätte ein
alkoholiker wer macht er der war doch
vergisst ihn bei dem man ganz schön aber
jetzt ist merck sowie die wie die nada
wirklich platzen und das ist für mich
ein erfolg glücklich dass ich es
geschafft habe um dem zu beweisen dass
ich noch lebe dass ich auch alleine
kommt weist aber trotzdem gerne jeden
das beste jeder soll sein jeden vor
jedem der vielleicht soll belohnt werden
am ende weil das ist ein harter weg und
ich bin auch keiner der sagt okay bei
ihnen sonst funktioniert bei mir sagt
funktion jeder soll das kriegen was er
verdient also und da bin ich froh dass
es gerade alles zum laufen ist also die
lage ist auf jeden fall auf dem besten
weg hatten zweifel daran dass er so
laufen wird oder wo war der moment wo du
deinen größten zweifel hatte ob es so
laufen ob so laufen wird
ob du diesen erfolg anders ich hätte das
nicht gedacht dass ich so weit komme
wirklich also nachdem mit sido und zu
halt auch so betont ganz ehrlich das war
auch so ich habe ich freunde gebraucht
in der zeit wo ich mich schlecht gehen
mir ging es wirklich schlecht
mir ging's richtig richtig kacke und ich
habe aufgegeben ich meine ex freunde
haben mich viel getrennt gehabt ich habe
freunde gebracht die mich anrufen und
sagen brauchst du hilfe brauchst du
irgendwas ich bin so ein mensch wenn ich
mir guten auch wenn es mir nicht gut
gehen würde teile ich mein mann mein
letztes geld teilen freunden
ich fragte ihn wenn ich etwas tun kann
sehr gerne gewünscht aber es hat mir
gefehlt
vielleicht haben doch zu tun gehabt und
ich habe damals zeit falsch aufgenommen
aber es ist halt so passiert und mehr
zeit alles weh getan
und da habe ich man sagt bei uns freunde
sieht man einen schlechten tag nicht mal
guten tagen und für mich war es so dass
die freunde für mich wie ein schatten
war
sobald die sonne geschenkt hat waren die
alle neben mir und wollte noch mehr
profitieren mit mir nehmen wir stehen
vor der kamera und gefragt wann es oft
kann ich da hinkommen kann nicht schälen
kommt aber sobald bei mir alles weg war
die sonne weg war waren sie auch alle
weg keiner war da und da habe ich halt
ein zwei freunde gehabt wie sido oder
andere leute von der straße von denen
ich so was
jetzt hätte aber das verhalten nicht der
fall und ich habe ich gedacht das vorbei
ist
es war wieder zeit verschwendete zeit
all die jahre war umsonst
und jetzt was soll ich jetzt machen soll
ich jetzt irgendwo arbeiten gehen ich
meine ich mach das scheue mich nicht
davor zu arbeiten weil ich arbeite gerne
egal wie ich arbeite
und mein geld zu verdienen aber irgendwo
ist man stolz darauf verletzt wenn ich
in berlin irgendwo arbeitet dann kommt
jeder zweite kleine [ __ ] oder jeder
zweite kann also ich guck mal war es
nicht geschafft die erdrich geschafft es
tut schon irgendwie und daten mit stolz
ist nicht mitgemacht und deswegen wollte
ich eigentlich einfach so weg von dieser
welt einfach ich wollte einfach sterben
ganz ehrlich ähnlich wirklich historisch
hatte gar kein gar keine lust mehr ich
wollte nicht mehr
ich war zu schwach da habe ich ein zwei
freunden die heute nehmen sind die mich
echt wie gesagt wir haben aufgerüstet so
die haben gesagt ey com na klar bist du
bescheuert was lässt sie das von ihnen
gefallen und das land nach dem film
bruce bruders das war machte finden
obwohl das war ein riesenerfolg war es
war für mich war dass ich sage immer das
war mehr erfolg für sie tut alles für
mich ich meine für mich war das halt
einfach eine rolle spielen man den
[ __ ] von der straße
dieses drehbuch wurde 212 3 zimmer
umgeschrieben ich hatte immer noch
coolere rolle
auf einmal wurde das immer so mehr so zu
acht drehtage meister handel ja ich
freue mich natürlich es kommt ein
bisschen geld drin
diese 5000 euro 8000 euro die ich
verdient habe da habe ich sie sogleich
der schulden bezahlt weißt du ich war
vor natürlich dass ich mich auch zeigen
kommt mit diesen leuten aber ich war
nicht bei der premiere war ich nicht
dieser ein paar der wirklich ich hab
echt das ist auch eine kunst
ich habe den leuten nicht gezeigt dass
wir so schlecht ging und das war halt
auch eine stärke von mir das den leuten
nicht gezeigt habe so weil ich wollte
nicht dass die wissen wie es mir geht
aber dann habe ich mich zu hause
eingesperrt
eine woche lang recht vorhänge zu eine
flasche an flasche hier und hab mich
einfach so wo sind meine freunde
das war das war ein tiefpunkt das war
mein tiefpunkt war in einen sumpf
drinnen der mich von tag zu tag immer
tiefer und bezogen hat wo es kein bock
hat er meine mutter war extrem krank und
das alles geht halt nicht von einem tag
auf den nächsten ich würde gerne mal
meine eltern anrufen und sagen ich
schicke euch ein bisschen geld damit sie
sehen dass mir gut geht obwohl die meine
eltern haben es nicht nötig aber so als
freunde so macht euch einen kleinen
urlaub am strand oder so papa und mama
mama geht gar nicht gut und geht es
heute auch noch nicht so gut und asphalt
nicht scheiß phase
ich bin froh dass schüssel hinter mir
das sitzt du alles gibst dein jetziges
album ab wie damit zu tun weil es hat
damit zu tun
ja das album ist du es hast du zwei
sinne so alles kommt zurück ich komme
zurück ich habe nicht aufgegeben ich
stehe offen reden und man sieht das
cover ist ja auch als bild von je wieder
sehr ernst gucken und dann reißt es auf
und du lächelst dieses lächeln ist
wieder so es kommen wieder gute tage wie
der deutsche aus sagt schon nach nach
dem regen kommt wieder sonne und auch in
der phase von dem album habe stellt auch
ein bisschen familiäre probleme gehabt
wo ich mich natürlich so auf gestärkt
habe mein vater hat einen herzinfarkt da
musste ich auch zu meinem vater geht es
war wieder so ein stoppball aber ich
dachte es wird wieder und so wie alles
kommt die guten tage kommen auch wieder
und ich werde nicht aufgegeben ich komme
wieder zurück und ich werde den leuten
zeigen dass ich auch alleine kann ohne
leute auf die ich mich verlassen habe
weil wie soll ich sagen ich habe damals
zum beispiel stoffel diese leute
verlassen blind verträge unterschrieben
wo ich heute mit diesen verträgen zum
anwalt gehen und extra noch mal 1000
euro bezahlen damit der für mich durch
schließt ob alles ok ist ob ich das
unterschrieben sind
damals habe ich mich halt auch freunde
verlassen und habe einfach blind
unterschrieben wo heute die securitys
von den leuten kommt dies um die sache
zu klären und nicht er selber und die
mir sagen nicht mal ein idiot wird
diesen vertrag unterschreiben
diese kröte die auf ihn aufpassen die zu
mir sagen sie dort damals seine 2006
seine erste million gemacht denkst du
erdreich ernst genommen weiß wenn man so
eine sache von dritter von zweiten
drittpersonen hört erst dann tut es
schon ein richtig lese dann lenken und
so wie für mich meine zeit vergeht zeit
drei ständen für loyalität und liebe
geschenkt für leute die ich echt mit
herz und seele auf der straße auch
versucht habe zu beschützen ich habe
stiche kassiert für diese leute
und am ende haben hat meine mutter mein
vater haben geweint und heute sogar
sehen dass ich noch dran also daran wenn
du dass ich kämpfen muss das ist alles
so läuft soweit ich wusste der schiene
bleiben ich musste da wirklich noch
durch diese tür durch weil wie gesagt
mein stolz hat das nicht mitgemacht
irgendwo in deutschland irgendwo zu
arbeiten ich habe es angefangen und ich
musste da wirklich noch das tun was ich
verdient habe ich finde ich das was alle
unbedingt haben ich muss kein ferrari
vor der tür haben ich muss keine
gekaufte wohnungen haben
ich will einfach nur das was ich
verdiene wie jeder andere das kriegen
soll was er verdient wollte ich einfach
nur das raus was ich verdiene
da habe ich mich echt noch so
zusammengerissen dank meinem manager ich
sage ganz ehrlich er ist auch ein freund
von der straße hat mir wirklich viel
geholfen
das sind leute denen ich auch wirklich
so wirklich dankbar dass sie mich wieder
so auf die beiden geholt haben und das
stoppt die kraft habe so etwas
durchzumachen wenn sein vater oder der
mutter noch so krank ist am sterben
liegt dass ich noch die kraft aber dass
durch zu machen
daran merkt man das leben ist hart das
leben ist echt gemein und ich wünsche
niemanden so eine art das leben ich
hoffe jeder das was er will ok hier in
deutschland nehmen wir alles schön und
gut es gibt viel schlimmeres und anderen
ländern die los sowas respektiere ich
auch so weißt du aber jesus jetzt für
dich bist du noch oder ist das etwas an
eine eine seite deiner persönlichkeit
die ich immer wieder einholt oder ist es
etwas das sie schon hinter den gelassen
hat eigentlich habe ich hinter mir
lassen
aber es natürlich heute noch sachen
offen die ich noch von damals noch noch
noch ausgleichen muss ich habe zwei drei
jahren konnte die spitze es war auch
eine harte zeit für mich
während die anderen mit denen ich war im
internet wo sind wie viel geld zu machen
und einem auftritt irgendwelche djs die
gar nicht mal da waren bei ihm weiß für
und das sind so sachen die einen
wirklich wehtun und die leute denken
immer den geht es gut der wahrnehmen er
hat ihn ausgenutzt jetzt macht er sein
eigenes ding das ist nicht und das
versuchen ein album
klären das sind so sachen die ich zum
beispiel damals noch wie gesagt konnte
23 jahren keine rechnung bezahlt war
selbstständig angemeldet dass ich muss
jeden monat 1500 euro sind damit ich
meine miete zahlen kann damit meine
versicherung bezahlt teil bezahlen kann
und das war nicht der fall bei mir und
wie willst du das machen von monat zu
monat es kommt nix kommt nix von uns du
hast keine auftritte gar nichts und es
staut sich alles auf und irgendwann
müssen wir hinten und denkst natürlich
wie soll ich das alles schaffen was soll
ich machen soll ich jetzt eine waffe an
den kopf halten
nein das geht auch nicht das ist eine
schwäche was kurz davor
ich habe echt sowas gedacht ich habe
schon sowas gedacht wirklich aber ich
bin froh dass zeit ein bisschen
überrundet hat mit herz seele
es läuft jetzt läuft mal schauen was hat
sich denn was hat sich denn so vernetzt
haben sich ab nahezu alle allein
gelassen oder hatte hast du das gefühl
das war so eine zeit des lebens die
wahrheit verbreitet ich bin in die
falsche richtung werden als beides weil
es am ende werden nur übrig und da war
nur die familie und das war ist traurig
das ist echt traurig so so freunden so
viel so viel liebe und vertrauen zu
schenken und dann am ende wirklich so so
im stich gelassen sowieso eine wiese
trotz vorne so abgenutzt taschen einfach
weggeschmissen scheiß drauf
jeder denkt nur an sich das habe ich am
ende auch gelernt wirklich jeder denkt
nur an sich es geht man um ihren eigenen
arsch ich war noch nicht so ich war
vielleicht war es auch ein fehler von
mir immer so gut zu sehen und immer die
guten seiten von den menschen zu säen
aber es hat bei mir ist geändert mein
vater hat immer gesagt egal wie die
menschen sind wie die zu diesen werde
nicht so wie die werte nicht so wie die
bleib so wie du bist
egal du musst nicht so wie das ist deine
stärke wenn du so wie du bist dann bist
du der verlierer da müsste auch so ein
falscher mann oder so ein ekliger der
kein umgang der schweiz mit menschen
umgeht du bist nur du hast dein herz
bleibt dein herz treue und das lieben
meine eltern lieben das an mir auch so
dass ich ein mensch und der auch wenn es
mir gut ging es halt auch mal wie gesagt
auf der straße ging es viel besser als
hier in diesem musikgeschäft und da war
ich auch keiner der umgebauten angegeben
hat meine freunde sind partys machen
gegangen ich war immer zu hause ich habe
gespart
ich bin in unserem dorf gegangen da gab
es familien wir haben löcher in den
dächern gehabt weil ich sowohl im winter
wasser rhein fließt wir haben diesen
leuten ich habe deren dächer gemacht ich
habe versucht so den leuten um zu helfen
ich war keiner der geld an frauen und
irgendwelche [ __ ] geschmissen hat und
teure autos und herumgefragt angenehm
hat das war nie meine masche ist es
nicht meine art
was ist denn dein rad an leute damit so
etwas nicht passiert oder was machst du
heute anlass kann mir das noch mal
passieren
da passt auf jetzt schwimmt eine familie
ist mit meiner freundin zusammen
ich würde gerne das alles so läuft dass
ich vielleicht mit ihr heirate ein kind
und ich würde die ganze liebe was meine
freundin und dem fall ich freue mich
immer würde ich gerne mit kindern
schenken weil da weiß ich dass ich es
falsch zu machen und für mich war das
halt auch so verschwendete zeit so mit
denen und ich habe bald viel daraus
gelernt also was durch den leuten sagen
ich meine jeder muss seine erfahrung
selber machen ich kann nicht stehen
leuten sagen vertraulich oder ihn nicht
ich kann nur sagen anstatt zehn freunde
habe lieber einen guten freund auf denen
du dich verlassen kannst weil sonst ist
es auch zu viel und man hat keinen
überblick gott soll mich von meinen
freunden schützen mit meinen feinden
werde ich selber fertig weil dessen so
sachen die ich alt aus dem leben
mitgenommen habe und sie müssen selber
alle aufpassen ich kann nicht sagen was
auf was sie achten sollen sie wissen
selber was richtig und was falsch ist
und bei uns sagt man die letzte reihe
bringt ja auch nicht viel
deswegen soll man vorher überlegen was
man macht nicht einfach erst mal die sau
rauslassen und dann später denken warum
habe ich so genau warum habe ich so
gemacht wir menschen sind alle schlau
genug und wir wissen selber was wir tun
reste und natürlich sind wir auch
manchmal schlimmer als tiere
wir sind so dankbar wir wollen immer
mehr immer das beste aber wenn dann
irgendjemand uns zu verletzt dann sind
wir nur an beschwerden und beleidigt ich
finde man muss halt die zähne
zusammenbeißen manche linken so durch
einfach stark sein sich selber treu sein
und fährt zu den mitmenschen es
wesentlich alles kommt zurück all die
guten und die schlechten tagen taten
kommen auf jeden fall irgendwann wieder
zurück damals in grad oder christlichen
kirche da sagt man immer bot vergelts
gott vergelt's heißt es zurück also der
will man wünscht jemand gott vergelts
gott alles zurückzahlen
egal ob du was positives oder negatives
gemacht was sagt man mir hat genau das
gibt auch bei uns auch ich sage halt
auch ich weiß nicht warum von deutsch
sagen aber so gott soll das doppelte
geben was du für mich wünschen oder was
sie über mich denken wenn sie mehrmals
positiv wünschen dann wird sie stehen
das doppelte wenn sie negativ wünschen
dann sollte das doppelte gehen also
verteidige ich mich auch und das hat
auch was mit dem glauben zu tun ich bin
ein sehr gläubiger mensch
ich glaube antwortet und ich glaube auch
an an dem leben nach diesem leben und
das ist halt auch für mich so ich habe
auch fehler gemacht jedenfalls zum
beispiel kein perfekter mensch aber ich
bin ein mensch der so etwas gesehen hat
und ich weiß was richtig was falsch ich
versuche ich alles gut wie möglich zu
machen ein besserer mensch zu werden wie
damals nicht meine probleme in alkohol
zu ertränken oder woanders zu finden
drogen und also um gottes willen das ist
halt auch etwas was dir deine seele
betäubt und vorübergehend erstmal wieder
abstellt ist aber danach kommen die
probleme doppelt zuviel ich versuche hat
wie gesagt alles richtig zu machen aber
wir menschen sind wie gesagt nicht
perfekt und den leuten da draußen was
sie über mich denken so gut das doppelte
also denkt immer und er soll ich dann
halt auch mal bitte beschützt mich vor
den schlechten ich bin ich von diesem
schlechten weg weg ich lasse dich auf
dem guten weg
ich will mit meinen ich mein gesicht
nicht verlieren vor draußen von meiner
familie oder vor den menschen gibt mir
die kraft das alles durchstehen das ist
ein schönes gefühl wenn man jemanden wo
man beten kann wenn man niemanden
geglaubt und ich glaube dass er hat mir
auch viel geholfen natürlich gab es der
moment wo du sagst da hat der gott am
meisten geholfen oder wo es eine wende
gab
gab es eigentlich schon ein paar momente
auf jeden fall die man in dem moment
nicht so recht gemerkt hat aber ein
moment war schon extrem
fast scheint auch am fenster abgesoffen
wirklich mein pfandleiher gesehen da
waren nur wasserflaschen
ekel wirklich eklig und da habe ich
überlegt was mache ich jetzt springe ich
jetzt unter oder nicht und aber unserem
glauben ist sowas natürlich als auch die
ewige hölle
man kann das nicht machen also das ist
das größte was man machen kann was was
das ist das falsch das darf man nicht
machen
und indem man derzeit war auch meine
mutter extrem kranken und ich konnte
nicht zur ehe weil mir halt auch nicht
so gut ging
ich wusste gar nicht wie ich darüber
kommen sondern ich hatte auch nicht mehr
zu verkaufen keine wertvolle oder
irgendwas das mit ticket leisten kann
und diesen gesicht haben scheint auch
nicht gehabt jemanden zu fragen kannst
du mir geld nein das ist nicht meine
masche danach hat meine mutter angerufen
in dem moment ich habe mein handy
geguckt meine mutter und ich unterstelle
und das war glaube ich ein zeichen
gott hat mein engel geschickt rufen so
lang und als meine mutter angerufen
ihre stimme hat mich so mitgenommen dass
ich gesagt habe was mache ich gerade her
ich hab mich so zusammengerissen dass
sie nicht merkt dass ich so lange und so
komisch reden dass ich besoffen bin ich
hab mich so zusammengerissen
ich habe gesagt man künftig früher noch
mal nichts zu tun sie hat gesagt mein
sohn miliz wird macht den kopf nämlich
wenn ich ab einen neffen in tokai
nämlich immer frage sagt mir die sagen
denn die wenn es ihnen schlecht geht die
wollen ja nicht dass die traurig bin
sagt mir ob es ihr gut geht oder nicht
und er sagt mir immer dass er gut geht
und an dem tag habe ich ihn auch nicht
erreichen dann hat er wahrscheinlich ihr
gesagt dass ich immer in anrufe und dann
hat sie mich anfangs ja mach dir keinen
kopf ich mir geht's gut ich warte darauf
dass ich mich besuchen kommt und was
mach ich da gerade noch nicht unter
springen sie wartet auf mich wie kann
ich es ja antun und seit dem tag habe
ich schon aufgehört mit einem das war so
krass von einem tag auf den anderen habe
ich alles auf schicksal ein schicksal
das schicksal auch ein bisschen selber
aber der kommt bei den nicht mehr raus
den hab ich bekämpfte besiegt ich habe
den sieg
das heißt es nicht der nächste stärke
ist auch mal so wenn du wenn du zum
beispiel gut machen wir zum beispiel
morgens wenn man morgens beim fünf
gewählten wenn man morgens aufsteht zum
gebet ist es da kennt man die meisten
pluspunkte weil du deinen süßesten
schlaf unterbricht für den lieben gott
gebeten willst und da kommt man der
teufel soll ich jetzt aufstehen oder
nicht macht das später weißt du dass der
teufel sagt scheiß drauf geschlafen aber
wenn du den besiegten eine stets auf ich
gebe mich das waschen und lebte dann
bist du demnächst mal bist du stark und
das ist beim fast genauso ich will
vielleicht jetzt mit meiner religion
keine predigt halten aber es ist halt so
was mich überzeugt hat meiner religion
auch dass man auf die sekunde wartet
bist du essen darfst du fängst du vorher
an und sagt so was schon bis 160 stunden
durchgezogen ist für mehr 16 stunden und
eine minute die eigenen mythos auf
warten bis der gebet komplexen und wenn
das gebet konnten die eine minute dann
genießt du dein essen dort ein neues
besiegeln ok dann viel erfolg dabei das
gerüst davon dass ist er nie mehr so
schlecht geht
ich hoffe niemanden bewusst